I have enjoyed every single outing as
Loki
he was someone who was essentially a
prince in a royal family who found out
he didn't belong in that family then
actually in his lineage is much darker
which is how his position as an
antagonist is born what's unique about
this experience is as an actor when you
build the character you build it and
play it and inhabit at once and it's
very very very rare to come back even
once let alone twice three times four
times in my case five times and
reinterpret and reinvigorate the
character last time I saw you you were
trying to kill everybody worried yet
these days in varies from moment to
moment he's charming he's mischievous
he's witty he's clever and funny but all
of those things are on top of this
vulnerability in this pain but that's
Loki's complexity is Loki is someone
who's always dancing on the line between
good and bad and I think that's
something really enjoyable for me to
play
see that you can see that come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]